[Music]
hey you guys tomes of terror time doing
another book review today now the one
that i'm doing here is one that i guess
i had like heard a lot about it because
like i said i watch a lot of other
horror youtube channels and stuff like
that trying to get recommendations and
you know trying to put my finger on the
pulse of like what other people are
reading and stuff and i saw this one
come up in a lot of people's either
anticipated or you know ones they had
read and stuff like that i think it came
out in 2019 originally
and i guess this guy is um
pretty well known for writing a
massively successful novel several years
ago called the perks of being a
wallflower and he also did the
screenplay for the movie and uh he
hasn't written a novel since then but
that's because he's been working in tv
and movies um he i think he co-wrote the
screenplays for like uh beauty and the
beast the live-action one and rent uh
the movie of rent and uh i think he was
one of the co-creators of the show
jericho as well so
he's been uh busy doing stuff and hasn't
gotten around to writing a novel until
now uh his name is stephen chabotsky and
this book here which i like i said i
believe it came out in 2019 is called
imaginary friend
and the premise of it sounded really
really cool and um you know indeed i
okay i feel like i have like really
conflicting like
opinions about this not opinions but
conflicting feelings about it let's put
it that way so this is kind of gonna be
like
i don't know it's not gonna be hard for
me to talk about exactly but it's kind
of like
again i might i'm not gonna like spoil
anything necessarily that happens in the
book but i might kind of spoil some
thematic elements and just because i
think people
should it's one of those ones where
the blurb on the back of the book which
sounds really good actually only
encompasses maybe like the first
half or three quarters of the book and
then it kind of goes in a different
direction that
maybe people aren't expecting and i feel
like maybe
that should have been disclosed i don't
know
it didn't really bother me that much but
some reviews i saw of it it's i was on
goodreads and it looks like it has a
pretty solid like three and a half to
four star reviews some people loved it
um and actually i kind of loved it and i
liked it overall like i enjoyed it
overall but i think toward the end um it
kind of got a little
something something you know what i mean
i'll kind of get into that in a little
bit but you know like i said overall it
was a good experience but
it's because this book is so long it's
like 700 odd pages it's like and this
doesn't even like i in the and the type
is like really small like when i first
opened it up i was just like oh my god
this is gonna and i'm not like
intimidated by like big huge books or
anything but since i've been doing these
reviews i've been trying to like read
a lot more books like more quickly and i
didn't realize i was like oh that
doesn't look that long but then when you
open it and the type is like super small
i was just gonna like oh my god so it's
like you know take forever but it
actually didn't really take me that long
to read maybe i don't know maybe eight
hours overall like over a couple of days
like two and a half days it took me to
read um because the first part of it
like i said the first
i don't know i want to say like 60 to 75
of it was like really compelling and i
just kept wanting to like come back to
it and then after that it kind of i was
kind of like oh it's going this way and
then i was just kind of like
and then i still like felt compelled to
finish it but
it started going in a direction that i
wasn't really sure that i was happy with
you know what i mean so i don't know
we'll we'll get into it so
uh the beginning of this book like i
said i kind of feel like
it's based around this seven-year-old
boy named christopher
and him and his mom kate
uh kate has been um you know she's she's
a single mom
and she was uh married i guess her and
uh christopher's dad they had like a
very happy life together but he has uh
he committed suicide at some point in
the past like only a year or two
previously and since then their life has
kind of been going down the toilet a
little bit you know she's kind of had a
lot of dead-end jobs she can't really
you know get or get financially get her
uh act together you know she can't get a
good job and stuff and she keeps ending
up in a series of uh bad relationships
with like really abusive dudes and
everything i guess her background uh you
know she grew up in a very abusive
household so it's almost kind of like
she's repeating the cycle and she wants
to get out of it she can't like get out
of it so at the beginning of the book um
she's with this uh abusive [ __ ] named
jerry
and um she finally decides she's not
gonna [ __ ] take it anymore so she has
been putting some money aside so she
kind of likes takes her son and like
sneaks out in the middle of the night
and goes to a place where she hopes that
he can't track them down so they go to
this little town called i think it's
called mill grove or mills grove uh
pennsylvania which is i you know i've
never i've only been to pennsylvania
once so i'm not really sure if this is a
real town or not but it sounds like it's
not too far from
pittsburgh
uh you know so kind of outside of there
but sort of like a you know a real small
town
type thing now the first part of this
like i said the first uh the bulk of
this book is very
stephen king-like it also kind of gave
me
vibes in the sense that
what ends up happening is that the house
they get at first they're living in a
motel
because you know like i said she's a
single mom and she doesn't have a lot of
money but she's really i mean the mom
kate is a really great character the kid
is too i really liked the two of them
and i really
wanted to see them succeed because they
were just really really good people and
they were trying really hard to make a
life for themselves and [ __ ] was just
you know like life was just like
[ __ ] on them generally so i was just
kind of like yeah you know i can feel
that so you know so i could really
relate to them and they seemed like
really good people
so she ends up moving uh you know she
they move into a motel she gets a job at
um like an old folks home like you know
like cleaning up like an orderly or
something like that and uh puts
christopher in the school and she even
like lies about their address she gives
them her work address so that you know
they can so he can go to a better school
and show like that now christopher also
has a learning disability um i don't
know if they ever say out right but it
seems like he's dyslexic because the way
that he taught the way that he um
you know reads it's like he's shows how
they see it it's like all the you know
letters are mixed up so he's really not
good in school and he uh berates himself
all the time for being dumb and uh his
mom is just like really sweet about it
she's just kind of like you'll get it
you'll get it you know what i mean it's
like it's okay you can figure it out and
uh you know and he's kind of afraid that
he's never going to be able to so they
moved to this town uh the kid you know
christopher starts kind of getting
bullied the old folks home where kate
works
is owned by uh the collins family who
are kind of like the rich [ __ ] that
own most of the town like in the you
know in a lot of these kind of stories
this it has a very stephen king like
vibe as i said uh this is a very like
dairy maine type of town where there's
like one family that owns everything and
they throw their weight around and be
dicks to everybody and treat everybody
else like servants so you have that kind
of [ __ ] going on too and also they have
a draco malfoy-ish
kind of kid who goes to school who's
like the same age as christopher so of
course he's like a horrible child but
he's not horrible like one dimensionally
it's kind of like everybody in this
that's a terrible person
uh in the town they have a reason for
being a terrible person because that's
one thing that kind of like comes into
play like thematically later on so that
was one thing i did like is that the
characters are not
you know even the even the quote-unquote
bad guys are not one-dimensional it's
always just kind of like yeah they act
like [ __ ] but they have a reason behind
that like sometimes they've been abused
or sometimes you know they're like i
said they're repeating cycles of
violence and things like that so that is
kind of like gone into so it's not like
a real simplistic kind of narrative so
what ends up happening is the kid
christopher he starts going to play in
uh this big patch of woods called the
mission street woods now the collins
family
is going to be building some [ __ ] out
there like houses and everything so
they've started like tearing all the
woods down and a lot of people are kind
of like you know mad about it but
you know it's kind of going ahead anyway
and it should be noted too that there's
like a prologue to this book that takes
place like 50 years prior in the same
town and uh you're led to assume that a
little boy named david who is about the
same age as christopher went into the
mission street woods and something
really bad happened to him like he went
missing and he was never found so as it
goes on uh christopher starts
getting um
and what seems to be an imaginary friend
uh somebody that kind of like talks to
him
and at first like he goes into the woods
and he sees a person but then the
imaginary friend is sort of like
manifested as this white plastic bag
that's like hanging in the in this tree
and he's kind of going out in the woods
and like talking to this white plastic
bag and he's fully aware that if
somebody saw him doing it then they
would say he was crazy so he's real
careful to let keep it on the down low
but apparently what ends up happening is
that he kind of starts uh you know
talking to this person and he
you know whoever it is
and good stuff starts to happen like his
mom wins the lottery like he starts
getting really good at uh at math like
he figures out like how to read and then
he he starts getting like smarter and
smarter and smarter and like turning
into a genius like i said his mom wins
the lottery so they are able to um
and i don't think it's like a billion
dollars or anything but it's enough for
them to pay off their debts and you know
buy a decent house and stuff like that
um so it seems like everything's looking
up for them you know once he starts
talking to this imaginary friend and the
imaginary friend uh basically tells him
what you need to do is you need to get
some of your little friends together and
you need to build a tree house in the
middle of the mission street woods and
he basically tells him like everything
to do like how to do it where to get the
supplies from so he's basically giving
him like psychic powers uh because he
gets to a point where
he's so focused on building this
treehouse and he's like starts to be
able to read people's thoughts so he
actually knows what everybody's thinking
which is good up to a point but then as
it goes on and he gets like his brain
expands more and more it seems like uh
it starts to become kind of like a curse
because
he's
so inundated with other people's pain
and anger and stuff like that that it's
just kind of like [ __ ] them up
and basically i don't think it's too
much of a spoiler
to say that this tree house
what it is is basically a
sort of a portal between the real world
and the imaginary world right so that's
what he ends up building so it comes to
a point too where he can go into the
imaginary world where it's like it looks
like the same town but he can like creep
around and like see and nobody can see
him
um so there's that whole thing and then
there's a bunch of like weird [ __ ] going
on too like
you know a bunch of weird [ __ ] going on
the imaginary world which i won't uh
spoil
so that's kind of like the setup and
like i said that's like the first
probably like 60 75 of the book and that
part was awesome i was just kind of like
i was so like into it i was like this
kid he goes into the woods he disappears
for six days he doesn't know he can't
remember anything and then he comes back
and now he's like a super genius and now
he's uh you know his mom wins the
lottery like all this crazy [ __ ] happens
and then i think his mom won the lottery
before he went missing but yeah so so
it's kind of like like i said i think
that's what reminded me of pen pal which
i loved by the way which i reviewed a
little while back just because there was
like a kid that goes missing in the
woods and he's gone for a while and then
he comes back and he's different so
that's kind of like the same thing but
other than that it's not really uh that
much the same as that book but that that
plot trope kind of like uh you know
reminded me of that yeah so he goes
missing he comes back and now he's like
really smart and he's like he's he talks
to this imaginary friend who he just
calls the nice man through this bag but
he also kind of sees him sometimes
that's not like super clear but you know
and he's building this treehouse and he
gets like three of his little friends to
build the street and it's like a it's an
awesome tree house too it's like way
better than any seven-year-old should be
able to build like it's all professional
and [ __ ] um but yeah and it serves as
like a like i said a portal between the
world and then there's also like a scary
element too because there's this
something like a demon or something like
that called the hissing lady
and she's like super scary she's almost
like a witch so so there's that element
too and that's kind of like going back
to 50 years ago the first kid david that
disappeared um he was
you're led to presume that he was uh
taken out of his window by this witch or
whatever so you're kind of thinking and
then the nice man is telling christopher
that it's like we have to you know do
something about the hissing lady she's
really bad and it seems like she's
really bad
so that's kind of like where the whole
narrative comes from
now at this point like i said i'm not
gonna spoil everything that happens
outright
but i am going to say right here
this is a long book and it's a
commitment
if you are not willing for this to go in
a pretty much straight-up christian
fiction direction then this might just
like make you mad it didn't i don't
really love that because i remember i
don't think i ended up doing a long-term
review of this book um because i didn't
finish it but remember when i brought up
uh the book monster by frank peretti
which i actually kind of knew going into
it was like a christian fiction like
bigfoot kind of thing but then once it
started going off on like the
creationist ranting i was like yeah i
just can't anymore um this one didn't go
that far this one actually kind of gave
me the same vibe
as when i was a kid and i was really
into like the chronicles of narnia books
mostly the lion the witch in the
wardrobe the other ones i didn't really
give a [ __ ] about
i did read them but they weren't all
that memorable lying the witch in the
wardrobe i read like a million times
but because i wasn't raised religious it
didn't occur to me until i was older
that that was like supposed to be a
christian allegory i just thought it was
a cool fantasy story like i didn't get
all the lion being jesus and all that
kind of stuff or as dom noble calls
jesus's persona
like that makes me laugh but yeah so but
this one this one's a lot more overt
uh with the christian imagery and like i
said i'm not offended by that
necessarily um you know stephen
chabotsky is was raised catholic uh he
seems like he's not super religious
anymore at least from the couple of
interviews i've read with him but
spirituality does seem to matter to him
a lot and the direction that this goes
is
absolutely like a
battle of good and evil satan and god
type of thing at the end so if that's
gonna like make you mad or just be like
oh geez really
then then i wouldn't recommend it
because like i said it's long and the
first
you know half to three quarters of it
are like so awesome and it's just kind
of like a mystery story where it's like
what the hell is going on with this kid
and this nice man like this imaginary
friend and this hissing lady which like
what's going on with the imaginary world
and the treehouse and it's like the
portal between the world why is he
getting smarter why is all this stuff
happening and it's like it was so so
cool and i i have to admit that
when i saw that it was going in that
direction i was just kind of like ah
well
okay you know what i mean it was just
kind of it wasn't just kind of like you
know i didn't like throw it at the wall
or anything but i was kind of like i
don't know it was like a little bit of a
letdown i guess and like i said i'm not
it doesn't offend me you don't you know
you can use christian mythology in your
stories just like you can use anything
else in your stories like i said i love
the line the witch in the wardrobe even
though you know when i was growing up i
didn't realize that that was a christian
allegory until i got older because i
wasn't you know raised super religious
like i knew the stories and i was like i
had bible stories and [ __ ] like that but
it didn't really occur to me to relate
those two things
i just thought it was a cool story so i
don't know so how you feel about that so
that's what i'm saying about how i kind
of wish
and i saw a couple other people on
goodreads saying this too that maybe
maybe this should be kind of market i
don't know if it should be marketed as
christian fiction
but
maybe i don't know that they should give
like more of a clue about that because
this does seem more like you know just
like a creepy kid he goes in the woods
and there's like something scary in the
woods type of thing and there's not
really a hint at the beginning there's
like a couple of religious characters in
it
but that's just their characters it's
not but it doesn't really give you a
hint until much later in the book that
that thematically it's going in that you
know battle of god and the devil kind of
situation i don't know i i feel like
maybe they should make that a little bit
more clear
another thing too is that the last part
of the book like the last quarter of the
book that goes in that direction now now
you know that christopher is kind of
like the the fulcrum of this battle
between good and evil
like this big epic battle he's gonna
like save the world and all this other
stuff i felt like the the last 25 was
really could have been trimmed down some
uh it's because it feels like it was
just like a one long
chase that could have been trimmed you
know what i mean because it seemed like
a lot of the chase was kind of like
repetitive it's just kind of like you
know now we're gonna try and kill the
hissing lady and now we can't kill the
hissing lady and now we're gonna do this
you know and it just and everybody's
like you know the nice man and
everybody's like chasing everybody
around like through the imaginary world
and you know this person's getting hurt
that person's getting hurt but it just
seemed like the same things were
happening over and over again so like
the end of it was a little bit of a slog
um not like i said not so much that i
was just kind of like i'm not gonna
finish it but it did kind of slow the
[ __ ] down so much and it was kind of
like a disappointment because i felt
like the first part of this was just
really really good and the first part of
it was so good that i could barely put
it down i was just kind of like i kept
wanting to go back to it and it's like i
read like half the book like in one
sitting just because it was so
compelling and i wanted to keep going
and like i said the characters of kate
uh the mom and christopher the kid are
so good like they're such lovely people
that you really want to see what happens
to them and like when bad [ __ ] happens
to them you're like oh man you know it's
like so i got really emotionally
invested in them and some of the other
characters as well but by the time it
gets to the end it just kind of like
drags on a little bit and you're just
kind of like okay like we get it let's
let's move this along a little bit let's
kind of see what it was and also i felt
like the ending went a little too
i don't know sentimental i don't know i
haven't read the perks of being a
wallflower which as far as i can
determine obviously is not a horror
novel um but it was one that really
seemed to resonate with a lot of people
it was on the bestseller list like
forever and it's just like i remember
they made the movie about it and a lot
of people uh really liked it it seemed
like a little bit of a sentimental story
and maybe that's his thing man you know
it's like that's that's cool like you do
you but i don't know if
i was that into it in a horror novel of
this type i just felt like the end was a
little too i don't know i don't want to
say because like bad [ __ ] did happen but
i didn't want to say it was like too
not sappy necessarily but it's just kind
of i don't know just overly sentimental
trying to be uplifting and
like i said i'm not saying you can't
have that i'm just saying that this
particular story i kind of liked would
have liked it to go in a different
direction uh that's kind of the only
thing i'm saying so it sounds like i'm
[ __ ] on the book i'm not i really
did enjoy it overall but as i said i
kind of wish
that the
last quarter of it had been edited down
some because it just seemed like it kind
of went on and on when it really
probably didn't need to
uh seemed a little trickly at the end
like
a little like uplifting everything kind
of
christian-y sort of message which okay
like i said that's fine and as i said i
kind of wish that i had known going into
it that that was going to be the
direction it was going to go because i
thought it was a bummer but i was just
kind of like yeah all right
that's if that's the direction you're
going to go like i said it didn't piss
me off the same way that the frank
peretti book did because that one was
just like an anti-evolution screen and i
was just kind of like really man okay
just just write a story like why can't
why do you have to do that but uh you
know so it didn't do that so it's still
good it's still worth reading but i'm
just like telling people if you think
that that plot twist or whatever you
want to call it or that thematic thrust
is going to
get on your nerves then you might not
want to invest a time and it's like kind
of a shame because like the first three
quarters of this book is so so good it's
just so good and because i was like
reading this i was like man i [ __ ]
love this i love this book and it was
just like really and then when i got to
the end i was just kind of like ah now i
don't love it as much
you know what i mean he's just like he
didn't stick the landing but you know
it's that's cool that's cool and i'm
sure like some people will be super into
it and that's cool too and overall like
you know i'm glad i read it it's just i
bought this at uh barnes and noble
actually i went to an actual bookstore
and bought this this one in mexican
gothic i think i picked up last time i
was at the bookstore because i had seen
so many people talking about it and i
was like okay why not i'll give it a
whirl
and uh you know and like i said i'm glad
i did it is very steven kingy uh until
it gets to the end and then it kind of
goes like cs lewis you know what i mean
so
if that sounds like something that's up
your alley then by all means pick it up
i'd be curious to see uh if other if any
of you guys have read it and what you
thought about it uh were you as
surprised by the
religious direction that it took just
let me know in the comments i'm just
very interested about this one because
like i said i really have conflicting
feelings about this one because the
first part of it i just loved love loved
like the first
60 75 of it and then at the end i was
just kind of like
you know i just i didn't hate it i was
just kind of like i just i just don't
love it as much now because it kind of
like disappointed me a little bit but
i'd be curious to see what other
people's uh reactions are about it so if
you've read it let me know in the
comments and that will do it for this
tomes of terror and i will see you guys
on the next one bye